today we're talking about google cloud
next i'm bicola and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
google cloud next just happened and it
was quite an event
hundreds of speakers came from google
cloud and our partners came together to
talk about everything from anthos to
xero trusts
don't worry if you didn't get a chance
to see it live we have all the talks and
attractive sessions available so you can
catch up on all the exciting
announcements here's a few of our
favorites
developing the cloud should help you
unlock new ways to work without locking
you in there is no shortage of
conversation around anthos and there's
plenty of new features to help you take
advantage of all the cloud offers
anthos for virtual machines lets you
standardize on kubernetes even with
virtual machine workloads and the anthos
multi-cloud api will make it easier to
manage gke clusters running on other
cloud providers
good security comes from more than just
the tools available it's about the
knowledge and best practices
the google cloud cyber security action
team gathers experts from across google
to guide you through security
transformations and to make your
business safer
of course we also have tools like data
loss prevention built into bigquery to
identify sensitive data and expanding
security command center with chronicle
integration
dealing with data can also be a
challenge driving business value can be
difficult if your teams are blocked on
how to collect or analyze data
vertex ai is a centralized solution with
integration across data proc
bigquery dataplex and liquor
vertex ai workbench offers a unified
user experience for building and
deploying ml models and serverless spark
on google cloud
lets you focus on what matters most your
applications and your data
of course we can't have the cloud
without protecting the earth that's why
we're excited to announce that google is
committing to running on carbon free
energy by 2030.
we're also launching carpet footprint
which helps you measure track and report
on your sustainability goals
activeassist is also being updated with
information on carbon impact for
recommendations and earth engine is
coming to google cloud to bring you
geospatial data at scale
wow that's a lot of announcements if you
want to read more or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud